previously on phasmophobia you're
looking for mark thompson
mark thompson got it
yeah you're some kind of idiot
it's not hurtful if it's the truth mark
thompson mark thompson
stop you stop let me out let me out let
me out let me up oh my god oh my god oh
no
no no no it locked
my god oh my god oh my god
[Music]
i am in fact alive i saw it it was
walking towards me
oh my god it was i saw the camera in the
hallway it was behind you
following you when you went in the room
it went across the hall and then slowly
came
back to the room you were in
okay all right coming to you activity
completely
zero boys watch out for massive spike uh
mark you're
saying he's at 16 dropping kind of hard
i'm fine i'll tough it through
i swear i grabbed a motion sensor but i
don't see it in my hands oh weird
sensors oh no there's no motion sensor
here in the truck
oh oh oh no
oh no not this room
right i got i hid in the room it worked
he was pissed off and he went to the
room where you hid before
did you get emf reading it went up to
four did not go up to five
okay the room you're in right now it's
freezing in here yes but it only went up
to four
motion i'm gonna head back to the truck
and get like a camera get whatever other
tools we need
yeah you know i'm gonna come too are you
sure you don't need to place that in the
room
mark you're at three percent of all the
way processing no sense
i'm coming i'm coming down
i'm also trying to make my way out
please don't leave me behind
i'm outside mark thompson mark thompson
mark thompson don't
stop you stop you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
oh my god oh god damn it
you son of a [ __ ] what have you done to
me
wait a minute i'm trying to run
oh my god he's such an [ __ ] don't
laugh
i hate you i hate you i hate you i hate
you
a test of your survival skills and you
did it didn't you
yeah i did it i did it yeah good for me
i also heard you
laughing up a storm
just
was it was it literally as you went to
open the door that it locked in front of
you because it looked pretty close
well you know it was also coincidentally
when someone started yelling the name of
the ghost
right as i was getting to the door
that's so
weird so weird so weird
it is weird it is ah man okay i guess
it's your turn
have we only got freezing temps yeah
have we seen orbs
i guess that was kind of my job you're
sure that we didn't get emf of five
uh no it was it was only four yeah it
only went to four
okay it might have been going there
but i don't know um are we all going are
we no no
no i'm staying right here i think mark's
probably not down for that i'm just
guessing i'm staying
right here you know i'll i'll help you
out i'll help you
i'm gonna help you guys you're about to
grab
journal and spirit box i guess here i'll
put the okay the thing back
i don't know we'll have to do uv light
after the fact because i've got smudge
sticks and a lighter which take up my
slots at the moment
do we have a video camera set up in
there for orbs no
no you know what i'll do so much things
a lot let me let's identify what it is
first i'll do smudge sticks
yeah yeah you do that man i can't
believe you survived mark you're so good
thank you you know i appreciate that
despite
everything yeah despite everything yeah
it's crazy
all the weird uh things happened not my
fault i just want to say that
yeah definitely not your fault all right
we're going in i'm gonna go into the
[ __ ] room and put down this stupid
camera
roger that is this alone or everyone
mark
uh this one is alone it only responds to
people who are alone
okay well i'll let you go first and then
i'll spirit box sounds good
all right you guys remember where it is
yeah sadly
you don't need to be so depressed about
it i'm not saying
there's a good chance that went to a
five or will go to a five so we just
keep that in mind too
okay i see you guys on the outside cams
you're about to get to the motion sensor
it's right there on the right
what's our activity your activity is
pretty low just went to zero
only got up to about four
okay i got i got you on the motions
no activity is that camera okay i'm
seeing the camera i'm looking for orbs
i see your breath i don't see orbs
activity went to a two
but it's plateau in there you should be
okay never mind you're dead
oh he's dead oh my god
oh my god run oh my god run oh he can go
right through a door
what do you mean he can go right through
a door well that's not fair
hello guys i got bad news you got the
most dangerous ghost it's
it walked right through a door so it's
definitely a wraith
can banshees also do that i don't know
whether emf
5 or spirit box okay
freezing temperatures there might be
fingerprints in there
never mind you guys are dead
even my lights flashing out here okay
they're okay
yeah i'm gonna come in i'm coming in i'm
gonna help him
hello you here oh i'm alive
i'm coming it was right outside both
your room steps footsteps
probably means banshee yeah okay i'm
coming up with a smudge stick
okay do you have your emf still no
should i go get it
yeah or else i can yeah all right i'm
not getting anything on the spirit box i
might give it one more go on the spirit
box i might piss it off again
okay so head out real quick and switch
out stuff
okay i'll just come up with a smudge
stick you go get the rest wait i'll help
bob never mind we're dead
never mind we're dead
okay i just gotta get to the room that's
all i gotta do
i'll go off the other way
why do i have freezing temperatures
right here
uh who's alive
i heard it groaning i started getting
freezing temperatures well as i was
walking
i'm gonna smudge this [ __ ] give us a
sign
i think i think wait that motion just
tripped and you weren't near
it i can't open the door i can't open
the door oh
hi hiding hide
oh smudging i'm smudging
are we we're fine like why did you freak
out about the door
i can't open the one door it won't open
do i need to say anything about the
smudge
uh i'm pretty sure you have to say like
a you know like some sort of
consecration or something i don't know
oh
go to your own room this is my room
oh my god
[Music]
hello
yeah well don't act like you wouldn't it
was literally following me the whole
time
oh no oh no we are all
uh wade yeah he uh bob um
huh we are all at zero sanity
yeah yeah um yeah anyway i smudged the
room what do you mean
apparently you have to be near the ghost
itself oh
my god did you get emf5 i didn't have
the emf i told you i didn't have the emf
i thought you were getting the ems
i'm a i'm i am but the door everything
with the [ __ ] i'm going to grab some
pills i'm going to go back is he alive
he's alive okay he's alive good luck
i'm excited for this opportunity to go
back in and die hey
hey
uh activity is at a four i think you're
okay for now wait i see you on the cam
he's not
near you
bob is that you
oh oh no oh oh no no bob
bob oh okay you're
yeah okay well wade is not so lucky
did anyone grab the uv flashlight
because i think that's the thing that
we're missing
he did that he uv the room where all the
action is yeah and there was nothing
what is this thing yeah i don't know i
don't know so what do we have right now
we have freezing temperatures
freezing temperatures it might have been
that the mf was gonna trip to five
that is definitely a possibility but i
see nothing against
the smudge stick thing yeah i know i
smudged the room but apparently it
wasn't
near enough to him oh wade's dead wait
you're alive
oh oh
there's no more pills oh we didn't do
the journal no more oh god we didn't do
the journal
all right oh i brought that in but i
didn't leave it because i was scared as
hell all right this has got to be all or
nothing we gotta go get
the journal and he's got the emf reader
he he literally has the only one doesn't
oh my god oh no here okay oh [ __ ] you
got a journal
i got that we're gonna get this ghost
okay we're gonna get this ghost we're
not gonna run away like howard's
right well okay i'm gonna walk in with
the crucifix
and we're gonna go get this ghost okay
you hyped
i'm gonna bring a camera so i can take a
picture of wade and i'm hyped okay yeah
we're
hyped let's go in the side entrance so
we're staying out of there
as well as possible that's clever yeah
thank you good stretch
okay we got this this is easy
it's cold down here already it's fine
it's fine
it's fine it's all good we're gonna get
this ghost
this ghost is dumb and we're gonna get
it oh is that his arm
oh that's not great oh that's also not
great
i gotta crucifix
[Music]
oh my god get back david
get back damon back demon
get back it's gone is it working it day
worked
oh it worked all right it worked great
job buddy
i'm invulnerable i can't be killed
let me get the picture oh there's no
insurance well let me just get a picture
get a picture of him anyway yeah make
fun of him so that when he's dead he
really knows how he messed up
okay yeah okay cold all right cold
where's my
here we go all right i got the thing
no readings journals right by the door
jesus christ okay i got no readings
no readings get those readings buddy i
got no readings
get them no writing no readings what was
his name mark something
yeah well don't we don't need to piss
him off okay i'll
hang on can you give us a sign mark
thompson mark thompson
mark thompson give us a sign nothing yet
on either thing nothing at all what a
wuss this is it's cold though
i ain't scared uh-huh yeah me neither
i ain't scared of nothing nobody and no
ghost is cool enough to scare me
how are we not detecting this thing what
did what did wade have on him
can i take any of it i got he had an emf
scanner and a flashlight i got the emf
all right well that's useless we really
goofed this
so what if it's not emf what is it then
i i don't know
we've got literally nothing oh
look at my journal for a minute there's
a footstep in there you don't want to go
in there right now
uh we didn't try the spirit box that is
the one thing i can go out and try to
get it
i'm going to go out and get the spirit
box and what else did you need uh
i guess orbs we need potentially which
is just cameras
uh i'm not sure
man ghost was super active killed wade
and then decided to [ __ ] off
oh hey hey guys oh my god we're getting
words from the beyond
do you do you have any input sir i just
want to remind you it was either a
wraith or a banshee so it's either emf
or spirit box
okay it's got to just be wraith then
because it's not emf
you're in trouble is he alive
yeah he's alive i'm alive oh good
that's good i'm bringing the spirit box
in we're gonna get this ghost
we're gonna get it
we're we're gonna get this ghost
yeah we're gonna get buddy okay good
just wanted confirmation
are you there oh
well there we go spirit box all right
[Music]
oh no oh no but the crucifix but the
crocodiles
but the crossovers he didn't know
anything
[Music]
man good thing he's slow
i'm fine yeah shop
yep stop fine
[Music]
totally fine yeah i'm fine okay let's
get out of here
i agree let's leave i'm coming baby
let's leave okay we know what it is for
sure how do we know
because we're geniuses right got it
where's bob almost there
sure would be a shame if mark thompson
mark thompson mark thompson mark
thompson mark thompson mark thompson
thompson mark thompson
mark thompson mark thompson
yeah man that was weird there's a ghost
that's been working with me the whole
time
ah yeah uh-huh okay
spirit box so it's definitely something
we think
it's uh i think wraith if we're wrong
after all this time
what's our other evidence freezing
temperature fingerprints freezing
temperatures and spirit box
that would make sense okay okay and go
through one else
i think that's it all right i'm gonna go
with that one
wade you got wraith i know you're
listening wade
all right sure we're wrong and i'm sure
you're like no you idiot
all right we got this guys we got this
great job everybody we got this welcome
back
it was really ready for you again
wait it was a wraith but i didn't get
the
i didn't get the objective for it
objective one you got it right thirty
dollars for objective one well i didn't
get thirty dollar for objective one
but i put it right uh did you put it did
you put did you do a good job but i put
it as wraith
it was wraith wait you got rape
did you put in all of the others yeah
must be an idiot no i had it as race
mark do you not rain so good sometimes
editor editor put it show that i had it
now everyone's saying that i didn't have
it they're actually wrong
hey i marked it down
as a wraith the editor please show
how that was true
everyone knows it everyone agrees
no one is disputing this fact and facts
are what are important when it comes
down to
the world we live in it's important to
tell the truth and i
always tell the truth i'm a man of honor
that's why people respect me so much i
know a thing or two about respect
it's a word something we've been missing
here lately so why don't you respect me
by agreeing that i put down the wraith
oh yeah hi mark so i restarted
there were zero professionals but i got
a professional this time and it actually
is the farmhouse
oh good i didn't know that it was like
limited by
the specific map that it was i added
everything i could
me um anything else we're missing i got
some money
the the game bugged out and didn't give
me the wraith credit
um unless you guys want extra video
cameras to set up we've only got one
video camera but we have our head
mounted cameras so we should be good
uh i'm a good farmhouse that's probably
not a big deal yeah well i'll get some
anyway just because
what you want yeah just just because i
feel like
yeah just because okay ready dude this
ghost is about to get god
this ghost is about to be discovered and
unraveled
and then described accurately can't wait
i hope the game doesn't bug out and show
that it's not not what i wrote
hey you're right bob
all right i'm fine i'm literally gonna
my first job is i'm gonna go put down
cameras i'm just gonna i got a bunch of
cameras oops i got cameras oh nice i'm
just gonna go okay
emf and i can grab like uv light look
for fingerprints i guess
no actually i'm gonna grab ghost
journals i'll do spirit box and thermo
meter
what are our goals i guess ghost event
what is ghost event we tried to do that
didn't work
i think i watched it kill someone once
and i got the ghost event
right so what's going on we have to
watch we're looking for elizabeth white
we can be together okay sounds good uh
i'll go play some cams on kind of come
back to the truck
and watch for the first round make sure
you all grab your head mounted cameras
oh yeah all right let's do this
let's get this ghost all right i'm gonna
put oh
yeah oh yeah oh you guys seeing what i'm
about to do yeah no i see
i see what you're getting at you see
what i'm driving at yeah you see
all right let's turn that on and bop oh
it might be a terrible spot but who
cares
okay with me goddammit heading back out
to the truck
all right boys who wants a code name
wade your squeaky and bob your tex-mex
perfect i am thick bunkus
if we see a ouija board we can also
interact with that oh is there one
on the ouija board yes there isn't you
can ask the ouija board
you can ask the ghost like where it is
it'll actually tell you what room
oh fine does anyone have a camera camera
picture camera
there's a bone over here by me here
inside
uh kitchen dining room first floor back
left if you're coming from the entrance
did you just turn the lights on here i
did not
activity just spiked up to a nine oh my
god a nine
activity it just yelled at me it just
yelled at me in the living room wait i'm
right here wait where's the bone
over here over here activity is now down
to an eight it just rocketed to a zero
activity is weird someone witnessed a
ghost event
who witnessed the ghost event it must
have been me because it literally
it literally interacted with me right in
front of the camera yeah
wade activity is low at one levels it's
not very mad but
it's being real talkative i've gotten
zero in the ems
i'm gonna i'm gonna ditch the spirit box
we definitely have that i'm gonna i
don't know what should i do
um you could try the journal do we need
a picture of anything we don't need a
picture or anything just the ghost
no we don't oh photo of it okay i'll try
the journal yeah
coming in with the ghostwriting journal
i had a journal okay put it put it by
the stairs there in the opening that's
why i was talking to it yeah i did
yeah so it must be just in that front
living room i wonder if i could take a
picture of it through the window do you
have an emf wade
yeah we just don't want to yeah emf has
given me nothing i'm going to take
thermometer and see what happens
anyone got a uv no on the uv i can come
grab one though because i dropped the
journal
fingerprints got a fingerprint oh take a
picture of this if you have a camera
spirit wraith poltergeist we're dead
mark we're not oh no
no you're not dead it's only out of me
you're okay we both got out we both got
out
it's still it's still just an eight it's
being really
strange not quite lethal yeah let's do
it again
poltergeist would be ghost orbs wraith
would be
freezing temperatures spirit would be
ghost riding what's the ghost level at
right now activity level
you're at zero it was at eight it's at
zero i'm not seeing ghost orbs
but it's hard to see with the lights all
on in there can you turn the living room
light off
okay oh ghost orb yep see it go storm
it's a poltergeist
poltergeist uh is almost ineffective in
an empty room can throw huge amounts of
objects also known as a noisy ghost can
manipulate objects to spread its fear
so it doesn't seem like a very lethal
ghost we could take a picture of that
or put a crucifix in the room i got a
crucifix and a camera
all right go for it yeah i got a camera
too i guess i'll head back in
show this poltergeist who's boss what's
the name
uh name is elizabeth elizabeth white
okay
i think it might be a non-lethal yeah
that's a good thing to say
squeaky your shoes glow all right i'm
gonna come in with something
did you put the crucifix on the ground
because it hasn't said anything about
hunting
they're ignoring me these [ __ ] are
ignoring me mark the crucifix trigger by
any chance
no i don't think it's gonna work until
you call its name if the crucifix is
like on the ground or something maybe
mark did i get a picture of the goat no
oh yeah activity spiked up to 10 but it
did not last
yeah i immediately got out the door
weird yeah keep calling its name
no i turned around it was already gone i
actually think this thing might actually
not be
lethal elizabeth white elizabeth white
elizabeth white elizabeth white
okay cool thanks elizabeth white
elizabeth elizabeth white elizabeth
white elizabeth white
elizabeth white elizabeth white
i hope someone is watching and is named
elizabeth white and it's just
absolutely perturbed elizabeth why
[Music]
okay she likes that i'm pooping in her
bathroom i guess
my flashlight mark oh oh oh i shot
did i get it it's right it's in the door
i got a picture got a picture i got a
picture
oh it's not stuck anymore run it's on
i see that yep i see elizabeth white
close the door close the door behind you
close the door i'm trying to draw it
away
it's coming for me now okay it's coming
for me
i'm gonna run around the kitchen
take it
yeah it's fine it's fine dude we're
ghost
masters dude we were baiting that ghost
so hard right yeah yeah okay i
definitely have poltergeist
here ghost orbs fingerprint spirit box
poltergeist
hey we're pretty good for this for you
all right i needed that 210 doritos
what a fat dub yeah pretty fat dub
[Music]